let's go back to the basics sure you
said something very interesting to go
back to you said that when Eisenhower
gave this speech and you're talking
about a five-star general in the past or
even the Clinton situation or even some
other presidents are you saying some of
these projects that they're working on
with UFOs or unidentified you know let's
just talk about UF was first and aliens
are you talking about this is a project
that's even bigger than a President of
the United States meaning it's not even
at that level that some of this stuff
they're not even gonna know it's
classified beyond the normal briefing
for the president yes and what does that
mean so you know you know when uh Bhama
became a president first and he went on
jimmy kimmel and he sat there and they
asked him a question and you know Jimmy
says look if I was a president first the
first thing I would do is okay I'm
president and I'm gonna go get checked
out to see if there's really a Lian's
and then Obama says that's why you're
not a president you know because and he
says yeah but tell me do aliens exist
and then because Bill Clinton said no
and then Obama said well that's what
we're supposed to tell you that's what
we're told to tell you and a recently
they asked Trump I think Tucker Carlson
asked Trump and about presidents I'm
sure you saw that when Tucker asked
Trump a so what do you think about UFOs
and he says I'm not a believer but
anything is possible he said that on the
interview with Tucker Carlson are these
our presidents you think like this
situation where the average citizen is
thinking about will they become a
president and they take them to area 51
they showing what aliens look like they
show them what kind of spaceships we
have and then they're supposed to keep
their mouths shut and they get all that
information does that happen or is that
just in movies that's just in movies and
it depends on the president let me give
you an example in the case of that we
had a president years ago named Ronald
Reagan and he was briefed in a limited
way on the subject but with a
psychological warfare objective to get
him to support SDI space you know the so
called Star Wars objects in space
and they're in a bubble you know I mean
Truman said and then Clinton repeated
that the white house is the crown jewel
of the federal penitentiary system and
that really is true so everyone thinks
that you come out of the Webber tree or
businessman like Trump or peanut farmer
like Jimmy Carter and you become
president and you have an absolute
all-access pass and that is true for
conventional intelligence and military
operations with the unconventional ones
and the proper name of that is an
unacknowledged special access project
USA P in fact there's a documentary that
came out three years ago that's on
Netflix if you have Netflix called
unacknowledged that we did it's globally
has had over 600 million views that you
can see the new documentary is is a
follow-on to that one but the
unacknowledged special access projects
is the proper military term for projects
that are off the books deep black and no
one is briefed on them who is not
doesn't have a need to know so you would
say well the president has a need to
know everything but those projects have
irrigated to themselves the fact that oh
no you don't and let me give you an
example I want you to I want to make
this less abstract and more concrete for
people I was at the Pentagon briefing
what's it called J to the head of
intelligence Joint Staff so you were in
the military so this is the guy who is
the director of intelligence for the
briefings for the Joint Chiefs of Staff
of the United States and he had asked to
have a briefing by me and some of the
people on my team because one of my team
members knew him and had reached out
before I went to the briefing I sent him
a document through courier that was a
briefing summary and that that's the top
document on it was a document that
listed some of the code names and code
numbers for those projects based on that
he recognized one of them he wasn't sure
what they did and he contacted them
and basically he was threatened he was
the first thing they said to him was
this is Admiral Tom Wilson by the way
and Admiral Wilson was told a sir you
don't have a need to know and he said
god dammit how can I not have a need to
know I'm the head of intelligence for
the Joint Chiefs of Staff and they said
sir we will not discuss this with you
when he continued to push on the matter
he was threatened with being demoted and
having a star kicking off his lapel so
you can imagine by the time astronaut
Edgar Mitchell who was the sixth man to
welcome the moon and I and some of our
people walk into that office because
this happened before my stand-up
briefing at the Pentagon he was furious
but scared and so the public thinks that
you know God is in heaven and everything
is in orbit and everything is that we
actually are living in a situation where
the extreme secrecy Eisenhower warned us
about the worse of that has come to
fruition and frankly no one is reporting
that certainly not the mainstream news
media so what has happened and what
would this sort of through the
looking-glass that happened to me was
that from that experience I then had a
briefing a couple years later with
General Patrick Hughes now four people
don't know who he was he was the
three-star general who is the director
of the Defense Intelligence Agency which
is like the CIA for the Pentagon is the
big clearing operation for intelligence
gathering and assessments and analysts
and the director of the Defense
Intelligence Agency general Hughes had
made inquiries through proper channels
onto the subject and he was denied
access so I was asked to come in with my
military adviser and a couple other
people to brief him and he told the same
story in fact he went over to his
bookshelf now imagine this I'm at the
Pentagon where the generals and admirals
that part of the Pentagon he goes over
to it in his conference room goes over
to the to his bookshelf picks up a
little eat he doll like you'd get at a
store toys
and he said furiously he says this is
all I've ever gotten in my inquiry about
this through channels as the director of
the Defense Intelligence Agency so he
was furious obviously and I said look
you're not the he says well who else is
in this situation I said well the
president the director of the CIA j2
Admiral Wilson yourself a couple of the
members of the Senate Intelligence
Committee I have briefed etc ironically
one of them was senator dick Bryan whose
territory was so called area 51 Nellis
Air Force Base and he had no knowledge
of this so now when I say this I want to
clarify something
there have been DC eyes directors of
Central Intelligence who have been read
in or briefed there have been dia
generals who did know and people say
well why do some know and some don't
it's whether they come up with the
pedigree through these you SAP
unacknowledged black black super black
projects and are trusted to keep the
secret so if they've come up through
that system they may know if they
haven't come up through that system
which is an alternative reality frankly
they're not going to know because they
haven't been cleared and read into it
and it's not known by the people
controlling these projects that they
would in fact maintain the strict level
of secrecy and who do this is not just
this is not just the United States by
the way the same situation exists in
Great Britain Australia I've met with
ministers of defense in in most of the
five eyes countries which are of course
you know New Zealand Australia Canada
Great Britain us and in fact except for
New Zealand I've met with mo D or
defense folks in all those countries and
it's an enormous problem because we're
talking about a major dysfunction of the
Constitution and rule of law on arguably
the biggest secret in the history of the
United States and when that happens a
lot of bad things
will occur things go wrong when things
are not being overseen properly and
controlled properly and that's the
situation we face so what I concluded by
the year 2001 which was of course now 19
years ago in May Maine I was almost the
the 19th anniversary own 2001 may 9th at
the National Press Club
we held a briefing for the press and I
had 22 top-secret military people there
and it was covered globally but as it
began to get covered by the news media
in the United States the intelligence
community contacted those media outlets
and told them to take it down and they
did so the other myth that people have
is that on the things that are really
important that we have a free press we
do not actually the Soviet Union had a
freer press than we do on this so
ironically there's a there's a really
big problem
with the u.s. function because of this
level of frankly corruption there's
nothing else to call it
corruption and it has really hurt our
democracy but it's also hurting our
economy people often say you know why
are we still using jet engines from the
30s 40s 50s or rockets from the 40s I'm
saying because the alternative would
completely terminate the petrodollar
system and oil and gas and coal and
nuclear power and public utilities all
of it is redundant completely
unnecessary now people say well then the
cure may be worse than the disease I
said no there's no disease worse than a
terminal event for the biosphere
[Music]
you
[Music]